Ron Paul writes the foreword to your
book you support the idea of Congress
auditing the Fed what do you expect them
to find well I support the idea of
ending the Fed because I because of the
attitude of Justice Scalia that
delegated powers cannot be delegated
away the Congress can't lawfully give
its authority to some private entity
even though this has been going on for
almost a hundred years I don't know what
will happen if the Fed is audited I
suspect we will find out that they
loaned money to Saddam Hussein and ate
in 1986 when he was battling Iran I
suspect that we will find out that they
loaned money to central banks of
governments that wish us ill that they
basically have been conducting their own
foreign policy and I think the public
will see once and for all the concept of
fiat money example when the Federal
Reserve wants to put money in the pocket
of some entity it doesn't write a check
it doesn't deliver a wheelbarrow full of
cash it uses a bank that's a member of
the Federal Reserve and it adds three or
six zeros to that banks letter sheet and
then it says to the bank now you write a
check well where did the money come from
that just added zeros they didn't put
gold in Fort Knox they didn't put cash
into an account they created it out of
thin air hence the name Fiat Latin for
let it be let it just happen money I
think when the public realizes that that
is what has been happening that before
the Fed the value of the dollar went up
13% 1787 1913 since the Fed 1913 to 2010
the value of the dollar went down 87%
the public will say enough is enough
here's a very quick question you know I
think that it's a fascinating point to
look at the decline of money the value
of money by the same token things are
cheaper now than they used to be well
things are cheaper in areas where
competition has been permitted remember
when a cell phone used to look like a
brick of cost about $600 now they
telecoms went
of them away and they're bigger than
they're about the size of two or three
in matchbooks that's an example of an
unregulated market where less records
there isn't anything that the other one
of your other lives is that there is no
free heart the other day at Fox News I
challenged my friends on the business
side can you think of any area of human
behavior free from government regulation
the great Charlie Casper Eno said to me
the elevation of the hosted mass I said
but the contents of the host and the
salary of the Baker that cooked the host
is regulated by the federal government
talk a little bit about how did your
worldview get started because you are a
you're a constitutional issue a few
years ago you would have been called a
conservative you're much more
libertarian now what what are the roots
you're from New Jersey is that where it
all starts is there something in the
water when I was a teenager I read two
books that had a profound influence on
me one was orthodoxy by GK Chesterton
and the other was the conscience of a
conservative by Senator Barry Goldwater
to whom this book is dedicated both
showed me the teaching that I found so
attractive which is the following the
individual is greater than the state the
free-market is utterly indispensable to
human prosperity and an unrestrained
government will eventually cease all
property and take all Liberty so if you
ask me what I do I tell you that I'm a
night watchman i watch the government
under cover of darkness
because when no one is looking it will
steal our property and our liberty my
views modified over the years you and I
once talked about my first book
constitutional chaos what happens when
the government breaks its own laws in
which I had examples of things that I
saw in my courtroom even a few examples
where the government took a run at me
personally in the years that I was on
the bench
it was those years that hardened my view
that the government is not your friend
I think it's also understandable even
though libertarians today libertarianism
today is so popular among young people
to get resentful towards the
the more it interferes with you and our
government interferes with you more with
every tick of the clock even the great
Ronald Reagan rose taxes expanded
government enhanced regulation and did
many things which were contrary to the
wonderful beautiful libertarian words he
articulated how do you feel about the
current moment on the one hand we have
this growth in tea parties and people
saying we need to restrain government
younger people being more libertarian at
the same time the nanny state continues
to grow we've just witnessed a
government run at health care or who's
winning who's losing what does this say
about the fight for freedom or Liberty
it says that Jefferson was right that in
the long run government an order would
increase and Liberty would decrease now
you can say blacks have more freedom
women have more freedom gays have more
freedom the government now enforces
civil liberties but think about the
example of can you think of anything
free from federal regulation it's almost
impossible to do it the reason these
chairs that we run now have five legs is
because of an act of Congress the
strength of the water pressure in your
shower
an act of Congress the size of the
toilet bowl an act of Congress the
leather in our shoes the tanning process
an act of Congress none of this is in
the Constitution but the public blithely
accepts it unless these things are
challenged at every front the nanny
state will be upon us and sooner or
later the government will run out of
other people's money and that means the
government will own the means of
production and there will be no freedom
left so are you optimistic that
government can be beaten back or is it
an endless kind of struggle it's
Moriarty and Holmes going over
Reichenbach Falls I think we we are
about to witness one of the last great
battles for freedom which is the effort
of the Tea Party movement the Liberty
movement something you've devoted your
professional life to and I've devoted my
present career to to promulgating will
take on the government in the ballot box
and if it prevails government will
recede the government once drew to it
people who loved Liberty
now draws to it people who love power in
my view this we don't have a two-party
system we have a one-party system the
big government party it has a Republican
wing that likes war and deficits and
assaults civil liberties it has a
democratic wing that likes welfare and
taxes and assaults commercial liberties
between the two of them there's hardly a
Liberty they're unwilling to assault but
neither of them is willing to stay
chained down as government you as
Jefferson used to say by the
Constitution the most liberal justice in
modern times William O Douglas said the
whole purpose of the Constitution is to
keep the government off the people's
backs even though most of his votes were
to help FDR get on the people's backs is
it hopeless no but are we nearing an
endgame in my view yes let me ask you as
a final question from your previous book
dred scott's revenge which is a
fascinating history of judicial law and
institutionalized racism in in american
history one of the places where a lot of
kind of orthodox libertarians were
against the civil rights acts of the
mid-1960s saying that this over the
government overstepped its boundaries by
transforming public spaces
or private spaces into public
accommodations so that we really should
let the free market or social sanctions
stop people for a big racist in terms of
offering movie theater tickets or hotel
rooms to anybody you're a supporter of
the Civil Rights Acts could you explain
where that comes from I probably would
have voted against the Civil Rights Acts
had I been in Congress at the time I am
a supporter of removing color from the
government's armament
so if Mrs Murphy wants to have a garden
party and invite only the Gillespie's
and not the Napolitano's she can do it
because it's her backyard
if Mrs Murphy has a grocery store and
wants only the Gillespie's and the
Napolitano is in it in my opinion she
can do it but she can't use the
government to enforce it because the
government can't make decisions based on
race the the evil spawned by official
segregation in this country was what the
government did and it all came from one
Supreme Court case called Plessy against
Ferguson this is the white car versus
the I'm going to use the phrase from the
day colored car on a train in Louisiana
this was not the defendant was not the
train company the train company wanted
the races to mingle the train company
wanted to make money they wanted to sell
as many tickets and have as few cars as
possible
it was the legislature of the state of
Louisiana that made them have a white
car in a colored car and the Supreme
Court of the United States let them do
it under the so called separate but
equal doctrine if Ali's rib pit doesn't
want to serve Italians I think he has
the right not to serve the challenge but
he can't call the police when an Italian
shows up okay I want to thank you Judge
Andrew Napolitano author of the New York
Times best-selling book lies the
government told you a chief legal
analyst for Fox News and a friend of
freedom thanks for talking to a friend
of yours